just too puny to to hold all the
literary characters I've read about in
my mind as we see our first draw of the
match
or our second second M yeah game
remember game two was that actually very
impressive game where Wesley held that
end game which we thought at the time
was going to be super critical Wesley
did go on to lose the next few but I
think that uh a draw is still not a bad
result for Wesley he has officially
stopped the bleeding in the last two
games and who knows maybe he gets a win
as white and keeps this thing close
okay caroon we haven't had a caroan yet
I always like new openings in the SEC
and Wesley responding with an ultra
solid uh exchange car this this has been
very very popular it's a good way to
fight for the advantage and this
structure also occurs uh as some people
in the chat will will know in the London
system in fact you could get a direct
transposition uh from The caroon
Exchange line to the
London yeah and you know how we feel
about the London we do not very
positively
I tried to delete the London from the
game of chess in a video we did last
week unfortunately turns out it wasn't a
good idea but all right um sorry
Eric yeah there you go although today
there was something huge on social uh
that there's like a Rosen score which
ranks the possibility for tactics and
and weird ways to trick your opponent um
so shout out to Eric Rosen and his
ability to break people's
hearts with obnoxious
chess did I say that right I think you
said it perfectly Annie as you always
do you know what else is perfect at
Knight on E5 which can't be captured
because forked that is a unicorn of a
pony and if you take it white takes back
with the pawn you get kind of a new
square at times for the other Knight
potentially at this at this point of
course it's it's not even an option
because you would lose a piece but yeah
that is a beautiful Knight and blacks
arteries are kind of clogged here the
way you play here with black is you work
around this Knight but it's not Pleasant
now if you really want to eliminate it
then you need to drop your queen back or
your F6 Knight back to D7 which we might
see and that directly challenges the
Knight I actually would have dro the
queen back to C2 in order to prevent the
F6 knight from moving back but I wonder
what Wesley Cooks up against Knight D7
here maybe it's F4 but F4 is always a
committal move in such positions because
you are weakening the E4 square but
Danny with that Knight on D2 Bishop on
D3 and Rook on E1 I absolutely think
Wesley can get away with F4 if he wants
to right now there's no real necessity
to play that move yeah it's a it's a
great point I'm also trying to
anticipate what was the idea of A3 I'm
like I'm trying to imagine opportunities
where the queen comes to B4 because if
that trade happens the a file opens up
so maybe Wesley was sort of prophylaxis
thinking about that idea down the road
otherwise it is a very kind of strange
not very aggressive move um and and yeah
I don't I don't quite know Magnus played
Rook C8 great move you might say why is
he putting the Rook on a closed or semi
closed file because Queen C2 there was
impossible due to Knight takes D4 so the
queen on B3 very weirdly is almost
stranded on the queen side can't go back
to D1 can't go back to C2 and instead
Wesley banking on his other pieces
preparing to double Rooks on the E file
I still like his position but I think
Magnus is doing a great job of working
around the Knight on E5
yeah you called it working around the
pony now it should I was going to say
now I was going to say it should be
noted for the first time you could take
it cuz you're no longer getting forked
and before I could even complete the
sentence Magnus does take it which is
interesting right he gets rid of the
strong Knight after takes he will put
his Knight on wait he just going to go
back or is he GNA get spicy in here
that's what's giving Wesley pause you
know 99% of the time you recapture with
a pawn automatically here you have to
calculate Knight G4 and Magnus is going
to pause here as well it's more up his
alley to play Knight D7 and Bishop G6
but if he's feeling brave you know which
he's not in this position he would have
gotone Knight G4 this definitely feels
like the human call this is a very scary
move to play it might have been the best
move actually but all right Knight D7
now you're going to put the bishop on G6
quickly to Def wait Queen B4 Queen H4 is
a really nasty idea Danny sorry to
interrupt uh if the Hile opens you can
interrupt anytime if you're talking
about sweet nothings on the king side I
love that idea that is a mating net that
I am happy to see
and I think Magnus has to take back with
the F Pawn again this is if he plays
Bishop G6 that would be so painful
Knight takes E5 by the way Bishop takes
H7 check talk about painful yeah let's
let's bring up the analysis board
because we got some critical ideas to
show in this moment first of all if
Bishop G6 takes D is pointing out that
you kind of have to take with the F Pawn
because if you take with the H Pawn I
think the first thing white does is
defend the pond da but this H file is
going nowhere and you are
in very very dangerous territory so if
you take with the F
Pawn that is ugly
AF yep I think I'm allowed to say that I
think you are too and instead Knight
takes C5 let's just very quickly show
counter the bishop runs into Bishop
takes H check King H Rook H5 forking the
other Knight it's so aesthetically
pleasing when you do this you take one
minor piece and then you Fork another in
the process and Magnus with a drastic
G6 wow wow holy Fork balls he's in
trouble and he knows it he plays G6 and
now Brook comes back to E3 which I love
this move from Wesley especially that he
played it quickly maybe there was
something better John but he quickly
knows just how devastating this move is
for black the bishop is trapped it's
ugly and he's like I'm only going to sit
here and try to find a concrete win I'm
going to defend my ewn black is down on
the clock and down on the position that
is a very strong practical move to make
so quickly absolutely and look at that
Bishop on H5 look at it carefully
because it might not last too long Queen
B4 earlier you were playing that move to
fer the queen to the king side now you
would be playing this move to prepare G4
and with the pawn on G6 it's actually
very hard
to find alternate arrangements for the
bishop you're not going to go G5 here
are you I mean that's that looks like a
devastating weakening of the king side
so you might have to get the Queens off
the board with Queen to D6 but white
could also Danny play H3 and reinforce
the threat of G4 Magnus is walking on
hot coals right now and he might get
burned
yeah I I agree with everything you said
especially your eloquent choice of words
the metaphors he might get burned at
this point I am all in and uh I I think
he is going to I think he he might get
more than burned right this uh this is
going to be a problem here I think
Wesley so is going to get his second win
and after AG three the one bright spot
for Magnus is he can play G5 there G5 is
a much less scary move to play if the
Queens are off the board um and at that
point he has no choice because you're
either losing a minor piece or you're
weakening your king and you know
definitely the the second is the the
letter lesser evil Wesley could also
drop his Bishop back to C2 that would be
a very much a move in his style uh to to
to prevent the black knight from having
that Escape Route uh in in terms of
taking the bishop so tough decisions
here for Wesley and I think he senses
this is a pivotal game he wins another
one and the lead suddenly becomes or the
deficit I should say suddenly becomes
manageable can he contain his nerves and
keep playing as accurately as he has
early in this middle
game agreed I love the move Bishop C2
and it is awfully Wesley soes is and
uh and yeah I mean G5 will be a move
that is forced at some point to save The
Bishop's life but it might be more than
weakening the king it might also just
lose the G5 Pawn right in some positions
where you can go after it and so
um yeah Wesley in the driver seat I
think he knows
it um Magnus feeling a little parched
and he clearly knew it took a sip of
whatever that beverage is
and uh here we go he does take it he's
going to go H3 he does okay G5 we're
going to see but Magnus could take the
bishop I would not take the bishop first
I would go G5 straight away yeah and you
know I think that considering all of the
things that could have happened after
magnus's 18th move G6 this is you know
it's it's bad but it's a manageable kind
of bad and now he's suddenly up on time
as
well I agree it feels
like Wesley stole a slight advantage in
a position where he had a clear one and
he still is I think in the driver seat
but it could have been worse for Magnus
for sure Here Comes D4 by the way talk
about counterplay mhm and we've seen
these games turn around not just 90
degrees Danny but 180 degrees Magnus is
definitely thinking about taking over
the initiative and D4 is the perfect
moment to do that now he's going to go
Bishop G6 I think to set up a knight
infiltration to D3 his Bishop ironically
is now the safest piece on the board and
it's White's Bishop on B5 that's out of
the game
completely wow what a twisted turn of
events there poetic description from da
the bishop has self-trapped with this
move C4 very nice move you're going to
put the Knight on D3 maybe even right
away maybe you take back first but okay
he does there's all kinds of problems
here for white all sorts of problems
rookie to Black has a draw in his pocket
Magnus could drop back to F4 with his
Knight and keep repeating moves he's
going to do it at least once I think and
then decide do I want to go for the win
here with something like H5 I don't
think so I think Magnus should go for
the draw and take what he can get here
half a point is great but that's why
Magnus is sitting at that chair and
playing and not me just goes for it he's
like yeah I appreciate the caution da
I'm gonna go for it 94 how about going
after the B ton Danny yeah why can't you
just take and take B2 I think that
that's a problem um and in fact mag does
because this Pawn is out of control it
doesn't matter what you win with check
your Bishop isn't playing it's blocked
by your own Pawn the D Pawn runs dancing
Donna baby girl Donna on D1 bring on the
lady D1 can be used also as a Transit
point for the Knight Knight D1 back to
C3 try them on try that on for size how
about them apples how do you like them
apples huh how do you like them apples 4
seconds for Wesley he's losing control
of the game
again Knight
C3 Knight C3 and da
unfortunately Knight E4 Knight D2 Fork
it's a double Fork here here I got to
grab the emote before they rematch I did
it boom